hey friends
we have done it we have hit 300 000
subscribers and uh it's just amazing
um thank you all so much this means a
lot to me to have so many of you
care and be interested in my little
youtube channel
so thank you all uh very much and
again to give back last video i asked
you guys send me
any question you want and i'm gonna just
go through the video here
and read as many questions as i can
so wow there are already almost 500
questions here um and i posted this
video
yesterday so really thank you guys for
for sending so many questions
um i'm gonna try to just go through and
get through as many of them as i can
but if you're not if you're posting
questions after i made this video or
maybe if i don't get to your question
right now i'll try to write you a reply
stella writes how did you come to play
the guitar
this is a bit embarrassing but it is
true
i was 11 and my mom turned
back in the car and she said to my
brother and i
um hey i have a friend who's a really
good guitarist in town do you guys want
to take guitar lessons
and i was forming the word no and my
brother
goes yeah and so i said yeah
so we signed up for guitar lessons and
uh
at 11 he and i started uh taking guitar
lessons and
uh with this this cool teacher who who
taught out of a
out of the trailer near lake and so
that was that what was the worst mistake
or instrument
malfunction that has ever happened to
you during a live performance
actually the the first thing that comes
to mind is
i was playing a gig in a church and
i had my music on my stand which i
didn't know by memory and so i was
playing my music
and i'm in the middle of my piece and
this woman that was in the choir
decided she was a little too hot and
there was these giant fans and so she
decides to turn one on
in the middle of my performance and you
know the church you could hear a pin
drop
in there very echoey church and she she
turns this fan on
and she just blows my music off my stand
and i
couldn't keep playing because the music
was too hard and i just had to stop
and then go pick up my music and bring
it back and i just looked at her like
you know what the hell um
so that that wasn't fun zoe writes
what's your favorite scale to noodle
around with you know
i i gotta say i always come back to the
aeolian mode the the minor mode
uh it always sounds good and it always
resonates
with me the major scale doesn't do as
much for me emotionally
i remember in in high school i was
particularly obsessed with
harmonic minor uh i thought that that
sound was so
interesting but i would say the timeless
standard for me is
good old natural minor
bonusdisk asks what's something you
believe about guitar playing that most
guitarists might think is crazy
um well actually i did a video about
this recently
uh i would say that most classical
guitarists think
um in general that playing uh without
nails
on very low tension gut strings
uh is a bit crazy um it definitely goes
against
the the mainstream um but you know
historically it's
it's what they did and um it's not
really uh
trendy right now but maybe that maybe
that's gonna change
[Music]
gunner writes have you heard the joke or
rumor that you are an immortal vampire
what are your thoughts on that no
comment
ryan writes what made you transition
from electric guitar to classical guitar
or have you always played classical
guitar you inspired me to pick up
classicaltar again thank you
i'm so happy to hear that ryan that's
amazing um
well uh i actually transitioned to
classical guitar kind of
uh arbitrarily uh i had to go to college
well i was going to college i didn't no
one forced me to go
um i was going to college to major in
sound recording
actually i had this idea that i play in
my rock band
and then i'd have a day job working in a
recording studio and i thought it'd be a
good idea
you know to get a degree in sound
recording but when i got there they were
like well you need an instrument
and you have to pick um you know pick
something so i was like oh
i play electric guitar and they said
well you have to pick jazz
or classical and i knew nothing about uh
jazz
but i could sort of fake some you know
um
spanish-like finger-picking strumming
stuff
out of nylon string and so uh i got a
teacher and i
learned some repertoire from guitar tabs
and i auditioned uh
with 30 minutes of memorized music from
guitar tab
and i think i equally impressed and and
offended
the teacher but he let me in and
eventually he was so good that he
convinced me to
uh double major in both and eventually i
said you know what
i love classical tar and i dropped the
sound recording and then
the rest is history next we have a
question from one of my patrons on
patreon
which by the way uh if you'd like to
support this channel
you can do it very easily by liking this
video
and subscribing or leaving a comment
that would help greatly
and if you want to go a step beyond and
help me actually
make more videos you can do that by
joining my patreon
and there are a number of awards you can
get cds behind the scenes content all
that kind of stuff
my musical arrangements so check that
out if you want to help
so one of those patrons sally hey sally
uh writes
how does one know when or how often to
change the strings
on a guitar well there are two ways i
would say first your
your eyes so if you look at your
nylon string guitar um you have six
strings
the three that are closest to the
ceiling are wound with
uh metal right and then you have three
which are uh another material nylon or
historically
gut like i have on here for the
metal strings if you look especially
around the first few frets where you
play the most
um those over time your finger oils
and dirt and things get inside those
metal windings
and they sort of uh tarnish the string
and so if the
if the metal which is sort of like a
silver looking
metal uh if the metal gets tarnished
turns
brown rusty uh sometimes i've even had
some students bring in a guitar that
with green strings on there from not
being changed for years and years
um so if they look really old and rusty
time to change them uh but also you can
use your ears
so if you're playing your guitar and the
guitar just sounds a bit dead
it's not resonating um there's not a lot
of sustain
then then definitely it's time to change
ann writes what's the most rewarding
part of being on youtube
um well especially with 300
000 of you uh subscribing to my channel
um the most rewarding thing is that
um you know i'm super nerdy about all
these
you know esoteric instruments and music
theory topics and
essentially uh i have this megaphone
that i can put out a video and and there
are a lot of people out there who
i know are gonna listen and be
interested in comment and that's kind of
a really cool
thing and i'm very grateful for all of
you okay
warcher asks who's your favorite
mainstream band or artist right now
any others not so well known um you know
actually in terms of mainstream bands i
really love to listen to muse
and even mumford and sons especially
their older albums
when i'm running or just you know
driving in the car
oh no the dreaded 4 32 hertz question
uh mr g i'm going to call you what do
you think about
different tunings like for 32 hertz
i have to say that the 432 hertz
thing is the the flat earth conspiracy
version of music theory
you know when you go back before
certainly the 19th century
but maybe even in the 19th century pitch
was relative
you know depending on where and when you
were whatever they're calling a
might be as much as a minor third low
and in fact that's something that people
who play early music like i do
have to really know so if i get hired to
play
a french baroque program their a
was 392 hertz generally
and so i tuned all my instruments down a
whole step
to play that music whereas if you play
um you know the monteverdi vespers
in monteverdi's time in italy uh
apparently
the a could have been a half-step high
at 466
i think it is hertz uh so there's
nothing special about 432 hertz
i have to say uh pitch can go up and
down and
uh it just depends on where and when you
were this is a good one
simon writes do you ever miss your metal
shredding from back in the day
uh yes i do simon uh what i really miss
about it actually
i think maybe even more than the act of
playing the music
was the fact like the energy
in the room when you gave a concert i
mean you know you work really hard when
you
when you rehearse and writing songs and
you know perfecting everything
but then when you get out you know to
the actual concert venue
you know when you get on stage and
there's this audience
who is so amped up and you know they're
there's
mosh pits and everyone's you know
cheering and like
it's it's so much fun that like that
doesn't happen at a classical concert
you know
so i kind of missed this i miss how
informal
it was and um sometimes i think you know
with all the
formality of you know how we perform in
classical concerts i i feel like it's a
bit stiff
uh sometimes and i kind of wish people
would be a bit more laid-back
intel void writes what's your favorite
easy piece
you know uh lagrama meaning teardrop by
or tears
by francis gutarega it's this piece that
i'll never forget
it's just you know burned into my my
musical memory
and every time i play it it's i find it
emotionally
you know moving and uh i don't think
it's
very difficult but uh that really
doesn't have anything to do with
you know it's it's beauty it's this
perfect little gem
of a piece this is a hard one uh zeus
infinity writes
what would you say were the three
revolutionary points when it came to
learning guitar or your three
revolutionary points
i think that the first thing i learned
which really unlocked
some musicality was uh how to sing
actually i don't think i'm a very good
singer but i i can sing
and i have to say that studying singing
and listening to a lot of singers and
you know falling in love with opera
and just listening to how expressive the
human voice is
and then trying to imitate that on the
guitar i think
the the human voice is the
ideal uh kind of platonic ideal
of all you know musicality and so
whether you play
you know the clarinet the harpsichord or
the the loot or the guitar
that's our our model for expressivity
and so learning to sing
kind of taught me how to then sing
through the guitar
that's one um two would be to stop
listening
for the attack the actual pluck and
listen to the
the in-between sounds the sustain which
is a bit
counter-intuitive because the guitar
sounds like pluck
pluck pluck it's a quick attack and then
a sharp decay
but actually if you think of the plucks
like a consonant
and then the sustain like the vowel when
we speak or sing especially
you know the foul is the thing that
lasts the longest
and so um you want to get through the
consonant the pluck
and to the vowel and that's what you're
listening for that's the beautiful
sound you're creating um so start
listening for the in-betweens
uh that's really important and then the
last thing would probably be
um the fact that uh technique
serves music and not the other way
around so
we have this our ideal of you know how
music should sound
and how each piece should should sound
uh
and then the technique is just the sort
of means to an end
you know you don't the technique by
itself isn't the music right so
regardless of where you play
guitar or bass or whatever the
technique's not really that important
it's just something you need to get
through
to make the right sounds and that's why
for the rest of my life i'll have to
practice because i
i'll forever have to be upping my
technical game to match my musical
goals there are just so many good
questions here i feel like i could sit
here all night
just answering these but i think i i'm
pushing the limit on the lengthy video
now so
i think i'll do a part two where i
answer more of your questions because
these are so good
well until then thank you all so much
for
helping me get to 300 000 subscribers if
you haven't subscribed
please do and actually if you like this
video i think that helps a lot
uh generate interest on on youtube here
so
thank you all so much and i'll see you
soon
[Music]
you